en corse dix mois après l'assassinât du
préfet erignac les enquêteurs semblent
se tourner vers d'autres pistes que
celles du monde agricole suivie jusqu'à
présent depuis la semaine dernière c'est
en effet chez les enseignantes
nationaliste que les dernières
interpellations et mises en examen ont
eu lieu un milieu qui ne reste pas sans
réagir alain chabod christian walter un
convoi de voitures de police sur
l'aéroport en fait le transfert vers
paris en milieu de semaine dernière de
plusieurs militants du milieu enseignant
parmi eux jean castela depuis mise en
examen pour association de malfaiteurs
en marge du dossier erignac
les enquêteurs reprocherait à ce
professeur d'histoire géographie en
poste dans ce lycée de bastia d'être
impliqué dans la préparation et la
revendication de certains attentats sàrl
est systématiquement nolin trick
monsieur castelas est passé à strasbourg
plus tard il intente à strasbourg donc
forcément monsieur castelas y est pour
quelque chose mais si monsieur cas cela
n'a pas pris l'avion le soir parce que
monsieur cas cela avant ville se
divertir il ya forcément un relais ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la construction
d'intrigants histoire ça on appelle ça
le révisionnisme jean castela
aujourd'hui incarcéré étaient également
chargés de cours ici à la faculté de
corte dans une filière tourisme pour la
formation de guides professionnels
il organisait donc régulièrement des
stages sur le continent pour ces
étudiants
son interpellation est une surprise
jamais pour pour un enseignant qui
auraient été engagés jamais aucun
discours politique n'a été intégré dans
ses cours en aucun cas d'autres parmi
ces étudiants ont été inquiétés comme
cette jeune femme encore choqués par ces
douze heures de garde à vue
je me suis en train de dire mademoiselle
vous avez la liberté de pensée ce qui
est autorisé par la loi
je je vous laisse méditer cette phrase
c'est tout simplement l'officialisation
du délit d'opinion avec ses 3500
étudiants l'université de corte fait
figure de creuset culturel du
nationalisme mais jamais jusqu'ici la
division nationale antiterroriste ne s'y
était intéressé dans l' enquête sur le
meurtre du préfet
aujourd'hui nous pouvons être quand même
inquiet lorsque l'on voit l'état passé
de la piste agricole à la piste
enseignante sans aucune sans aucun
élément cela pour nous cela s'apparente
à la chasse aux sorcières alors en signe
de désapprobation étudiants et
enseignants appellent ici à une
manifestation en milieu de semaine
proche